China's government is easing up on its regulations.
It recently removed license requirements for foreign and joint venture lenders...
...in a number of financial services.
And in January, China said it would open the country to foreign investment,...
...including easing limits on investment in banks and other financial institutions.
There's also been newly established free trade zones...
...identified in both Shanghai and Shenzhen,...
...which allows unprecedented economic freedoms,...
...similar to what can happen in Hong Kong.
The global financial system is starting to take China,...
...not necessarily Hong Kong, more seriously.
Last year, China's currency, the yuan, was added to the IMF's global basket of currencies,...
...which are currencies deemed safe and reliable,...
...joining the dollar, euro, yen and the pound.